please sit down dr. Hearst
I am doctor Roy please don't stare I
apologize for the search but we cannot
be entirely sure you were genuine we've
had quite a few people over the last few
months who sought to cause problems with
us but enough of that our friend in the
foundation gave me quite a bit of
information about you dr. Hurst of
course we have people in the foundation
your friend David I believe just last
week he sent us information on six
possible recruits David gave you quite a
glowing review just what we need a
brilliant mind and able to do what must
be done now that last one gives me hope
let's have a look at this file shall we
you're involved in the Alaska incident
that was magnificent you should be proud
the research data alone was extremely
useful as I can see a few casualties but
these cannot be avoided in our line of
work can they and you used another item
to stop it you've been wasting your time
at the foundation doctor you obviously
belong with us perhaps it's time I tell
you what it is we do here in essence we
are very similar to the organization you
just left we're not as big I admit but I
feel that our very nature means we
achieve more much more as you will see
during your career with us we have 326
items currently in our possession
actually with your welcome gift we now
have 327 take for example the human
serum
inject it into any animal and it will
morph and twist into the approximate
shape of a human the samples that they
had they locked away but we had better
ideas we injected it into a human hello
the results this is what you will do do
what is not right to do because nobody
else is able to do it it is for the good
of the world doctor we have many more
test subjects than the foundation the
officials in the countries we place our
facilities pay us to take they're poor
they're destitute they useless the
people we use have nothing they are are
nothing but we can take them use them
and then they are something out they
they are the future I hope that in the
future wars will not be fought with guns
they will be fought with impossible
things wars will be ended in an instant
they can be ended before they began I'm
not evil but the things we do have to be
done we will give you 30 test subjects
for your first two months and access to
two vertical items you would call these
safe items we don't bright new ideas
doctor for a bright new future impress
me doctor I'm sure you will exceed all
of our expectations you are to use the
items on the test subjects as I'm sure
you know how to keep trying until you
find that moment where it all clicks and
you're holding something that should not
be in your hands when you find you're
holding a weapon you've done it it's
another small step doctor another small
step
oh the name we are a small force against
the tide of impossibility and this small
force seeks to create logic out of a
logic what better name the McKay
insurgency